NOW IS STEPHEN MILLER, FORMER
SENIOR ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT
TROUT.
EVEN, WITHOUT TAKING
ACCOUNTABILITY HERE, HAVING ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR OWN
ACTIONS, THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO INFLICT PAIN ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BY NOT ENFORCIN
OUR BORDER PERIOD IN THEIR
BLAMING THE END OF COVID POLICY?
>> IT'S AN ENTIRE VOLUNTARY
CHOICE ON THEIR PART WHICH MAKE
IT ALL THE MORE OUTRAGEOUS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CLICKED INTO
PLACE A SERIES OF POLICIES TO
ENSURE SWIFT ORDER RETURNS AND
DEPORTATIONS.
AT THE CENTERPIECE OF THAT IN
2020 WAS THE AUTHORITY TITLED 42
.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
VOLUNTARILY PLANNING TO RIP OUT
THIS POLICY IN TO LET EVEN MORE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THEY CANNOT BLAME RUSSIA OR
VLADIMIR PUTIN OR ANYBODY ELSE
FOR THIS, THEY ARE WILLFULLY
DESTROYING OUR BORDER BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SENT FOX
ABOUT THE BORDER, WE ARE DOING
OUR DUE DILIGENCE TO PREPARE FO
POTENTIAL CHANGES AT THE BORDER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
TO RESTORE FAIRNESS AND HUMANIT
TO OUR.
GOOD GOVERNMENT APPARENTLY MEAN
OPEN BORDERS.
>> AND THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW OF FIGURING OUT HOW
THEY CAN GET ALL OF THE ILLEGAL
ALIENS THAT WILL BE ARRIVING
INTO A CITY NEAR YOU AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
THE ONLY PLAN THAT IS TAKING
PLACE AND THE WHITE HOUSE AND I
DHS IS THEY ARE GOING TO FIND
VOLUNTEERS AND NONGOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND FEDERAL
WORKERS TO TAKE THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND PUT THEM IN OHIO
OR WISCONSIN AND BRING THEM TO
INDIANA AND EVERY OTHER STATE
AND THE COUNTRY.
THAT THE ONLY PLANNING THEY ARE
DOING.
THEY SPEAK TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE LIKE WE ARE FOOLS, LIKE
WE ARE IDIOTS AND WE CAN'T SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH OUR OWN
EYES.
ITS PROPAGANDA, BUT IT'S CHEAP
PATHETIC PROPAGANDA AT THAT.
>> SO PUTIN IS SOLELY TO BLAME
FOR THE RISING GAS PRICES AND
THE END OF COVID IS TO BLAME FO
THE BORDER.
>> IT'S SPRING'S FAULT, IT'S TH
WEATHER'S FAULT FOR IT IT'S THE
POSITION OF THE PLANETS IN
RELATION TO THE SUN THAT'S
ULTIMATELY WHO IS TO BLAME FOR
IT.
>> WHEN THE UKRAINE STORY IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS IT IS.
IT IS IMPORTANT.
YOU NOTICE HOW THE BORDER
REPORTING IS KIND OF FADED INTO
THE BACKGROUND.
ONLY OUR COUNTRY, NO BIG DEAL.
>> IT'S NOT BY ACCIDENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING A
TRULY HORRENDOUS JOB IN EUROPE,
THEY KNEW FOR MONTHS IN ADVANCE
ABOUT THE INVASION, THEIR
STRATEGY WAS A CATASTROPHIC
FAILURE, BUT IT CAN'T BE DENIED
THAT THEY ARE TALKING ENDLESSLY
ABOUT UKRAINE AND ONLY UKRAINE
BECAUSE IF NOTHING ELSE, IT
PROVIDES A CHANCE TO TAKE THE
FOCUS OFF OF OUR OWN SOUTHERN
BORDER WHICH, THERE IS NARCO WA
HAPPENING AT THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT WAR.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS BEING KILLED BY DRUGS
MANY ARE ALSO BEING KILLED BY
GANG MEMBERS COMING ACROSS THAT
BORDER.
ITS OUR COUNTRY AND WE SHOULD
CARE